在上一期结束后
很多同学反馈希望有反射系统的代码讲解
应同学们的要求
这一期我们讲解pico引擎中的反射系统
反射系统的实现细节比较繁琐
所以同学们可要耐心
一步一步一步一步听完
才能搞明白他究竟是怎么工作的
如果想要有更多的交流
欢迎加入我们的pico开发者qq频道
我们的知乎账号games 104官方也开了
可以关注
并且邀请我们来答题
关于反射系统在引擎中扮演的角色
和pico小引擎中反射系统实现的大致思路
在game 104第14期中的反射部分都有讲解
我这里就不再赘述了
本期视频主要给大家讲解
pico反射系统的使用方式
具体实现和修改扩充方式
首先我们看到这个数据流图
它展现了pico反射系统从编译
收集信息到生成代码的整个流程
首先是从pico para的源码构建出
我们的pico para
在我们第一次代码讲解中提到过
pico para的源码放在这里
在semit创建pico rontime工程的过程中
我们会收集到pico rontime的所有头文件的路径
收集完成后
会通过这些路径生成一个puzzle header.h文件
他在这里
他的内容就是include所有引擎源码的头文件
然后simc构建pillow runtime工程之前
会先构建pico precompile工程
在构建precompile工程的过程中
会调用pico para去解析puzer header.h
这个文件里包含的
所有pico run time的点h都会被解析
解析的方式是通过con库
拿到所有类的抽象语法树
根据我们在类上打的标签
筛选出我们感兴趣的信息
比如一个类
它需要反射的字段的类型和变量名等信息
下一步是根据这些收集到的信息
生成一些c加加代码
第一次解读的时候也提到过
所有代码都会被生成到这个
generated的文件夹里
最后这些生成的代码
与piccolo rontime的其他源码一起
编译出pillow run time
在这过程中我们可以看到
其实真正进入pillow run time
发挥反射作用的
就是生成的generated文件夹里面的代码
我们可以看看这些生成的代码是什么样的
可以看到整个文件由三个部分组成
首先是一个type motor component operator
然后是一个type rapper register
注册函数
the operator中的一些函数收集了起来
然后下面是一个type rapers注册函数
调用前面这个注册函数
我们看一下原来motor component
点h的代码是怎么样的
可以看到这个文件里只有motor
component这一个类
这个类只有motor component resource
这个字段标记了mea abel
它继承于component
再仔细看看生成的文件
这里面的operator类里
第一类函数是取类名
通过jason构造以及转化成jason的这三个函数
第二类是基于机类相关的函数
就一个取得鸡肋的反射实力
第三类the fields也就是字段
我们可以看到有五个函数
都是以motor resource结尾的
也就是motor component类当中
唯一被标记了mea enable的字段的名字
这五个函数也很简单
取类型名
取变量名
set get函数以及是否是数组
我们对s t d vector容器做了特殊处理
如果是std vector容器
这里就会返回true
然后是type rap register
这个函数以motor component类名作为后缀
它首先是把那个字段的五个函数
组成了一个元组
注册进了field map
然后把base class相关的函数注册进了class map
最后的type rappers里面就简单套了个娃
我们可以看一下
更复杂的文件生成出来是怎么样的
可以看到它的结构是一样的
无非就是各部分的数量有所不同
它有三个类对应的operator
同时也有三个对应的type rapper register
这些operator里面也同样是三部分
无非就是fields里面有多组这样的五个函数
在type rap register
也需要把这多组都注册到field map里面
我们再看一下整个reflection目录
你会发现这个文件夹里所有的文件
除了这个or reflection
其他都是以reflection.j.h结尾的
而且里面的结构都是一样的
看看这个all reflection很简单
就是include以reflection jn.h结尾的文件
然后在这个唯一的函数meta register函数里
调用那些文件里面的type rapers register
这个matter register的同学们是不是有一点点眼熟
他就是我们第一次解读中提到过的
会在start engine里面最先调用的函数
所以在这个函数被调用以后
我们终于把所有收集到的所有类和字段的信息
添加到了这几个map里面
以供我们在运行时使用好了
讲了这么久
是时候动手了
为了让同学们对反射系统的使用
有更具体的理解
我们扩充一下
在第一次代码讲解中引入的lua component
给它添加一个get函数和set函数
让它能够与引擎中的component有简单的交互
然后我们通过这两个set和get函数
让小白人在静止和移动状态下
拥有不同的跳跃高度
观察一下motor component
要让小白人的表现按照预期
我们的lua脚本
要能够获取motor component的is moving字段
同时如果要改变小白人的跳跃高度的话
我们需要能够修改motor resource里面的i jump
heat可以看到motor component
resource标记的fields
也就是所有字段都会反射
而motor component它指标记了whitelist field
也就是只有标记了mea enable的字段
才会参与反射
我们给ais movie加上meta enable
然后我们在lower onent里面添加两个函数
set和get
这两个函数都接收一个game object以及一个字段名
然后我们实现一下这两个函数
首先简单实现一下
就只是打印一些log
都只是简单的把字段名给打印出来
然后我们再把这两个函数
传递给我们的lua虚拟机
我们现在只需要简单的set float和gb
当然其他类型也可以像这样子添加
接下来我们修改一下player的资源文件
把我们前面写的print hello world
改成我们想要的逻辑
就是先判断一下motor
component上面的is moving字段
然后再去set motor component上面有motor resource
它的jump heat
如果正在移动的话
将它设为十
否则设为五
在get里面我们先简单写一个return to
然后不要忘了把game object也传递给我们的lua
虚拟机
跑起来看一看
可以看到现在命令行已经在打印
我们get和set的两个字段
接下来我们真正的实现get和set函数
我们首先取得所有的components
然后将field name拆分一下
取出点前面的第一个字符串
也就是component的名字
然后我们在所有的components里面遍历
找出名字等于我们的component名字的component
之后通过这个component的名字取得他的type ma
我们可能希望能够更加面向对象的去查询
类型信息
所以我们封装了两个类
type meta和field sensor
这两个类的结构很简单
就是帮我们去查询那几个map
我就不赘述了
同学们可以自己看看
然后再迭代的去取得这个component上面的字段
我们可以通过meta上面的data fields list
取得这一个类型上面所有field的信息
然后再在其中找到名字
等于我们要查找的field
最后我们在set和get里面
调用我们刚刚编写的迭代
寻找到目标field的函数
取得目标field之后
可以调用field processor desi去set这个字段
以及get去取得这个阶段的内容
好可以看到游戏已经运行起来了
然后我们在原地跳的话
是跳不过墙那么高的
但是当我们移动就可以跳过墙嗯
卡住了
移动不了了
我们先我们先来回顾一下刚才写的代码
然后保存提交一下吧
在刚才的事例中
可以看到小白人卡死在了墙里面
我们可以假装我们的motor component
它有一个脱离卡死功能
然后我们要怎么样才能让我们的lua脚本
调用到脱离卡死功能的函数呢
在前面我们发现
其实我们的反射系统它是只能够反射字段的
接下来我们来给我们的反射系统扩充一下
让它能反射一个最简单的函数吧
假如我们的反射系统提供了反射函数的功能
那么我们应该怎么使用呢
可能有一个标签叫做whitelist methods
然后我们要给我们的get off stuck dead
添加一个letter enable
用于提醒我们的反射系统
我们希望反射这个函数
然后在我们的lua component里面
会有一个invoke函数
还跟set和get差不多
同样我们需要把它传递给我们的lua虚拟机
然后修改一下我们的lua代码
在尾部调用一下
motor component的get off stuff that函数
我们先保存一下这部分的代码
接下来就是在我们的pico para里面真正的解析
然后生成我们的函数反射相关的代码
我们可以先看一下
现在的pico para是怎么工作的
可以看一下main函数
首先是处理了一下参数
然后把这些参数传递给了pass函数
然后在pass函数当中实例化了一个puzzle
调用了pass pass函数
pass pass函数当中
就是用c浪处理了一下我们的源码
最后调用了一个build class a s t
就是在所有的根节点里面
找到class的声明和struct的声明
然后构造了许多class
把它们传递到了schemer module里面
我们看一下class类是怎么样的
可以看到在class的构造函数里面
我们遍历了class节点下面所有的子节点
然后对base specifier和field declaration
进行了特殊的处理
对于每个field declaration
我们构造了fid类
我们可以看一下field的构造函数
它简单的把当前field的声明的一些信息
比如说is kname type等信息存储了下来
我们可以仿照feel的类编写我们的method的类
去掉多余的代码
然后简单实现一下
在这个is accessible里面
可以看到有一些fields和whitefields的标签
我们仿照它编写我们的method和white list
methods标签
然后在这里替换一下
这样我们的method的类就写好了
然后我们在class的构造函数里面添加
对我们method的特殊处理
同时在class里面添加一个m methods的
这样子我们就把我们method的信息收集起来了
当然这里我们还需要修改一下should compile函数
因为原来一个类只有fields标记了才需要compile
但现在加入了method
好
接下来下一步就是如何把我们收集到的信息
生成出代码了
我们看一下这个generate函数
首先把这里的should compile fields
替换成should compile
然后我们观察一下这个函数
它里面的关键部分其实就是generate plus
render data
这部分就是把我们收集到的信息
转换成我们使用的代码生成库
must sth
它能够识别的数据结构
然后根据我们模板去渲染出我们的代码
我们在这里可以仿照一下这里的fields的模板
编写methods的模板
most style是具体的语法可以查看
most st是官方的文档
在这里我们的method只需要两段函数
就是get method name和invoke函数
当然还有下面的
将我们的methods
两个相关函数注册到我们的map里面
同样也是模仿duce的写法
然后再把我们methods相关的结构给传递出去
b一下可以看到
修复一下笔误
因为mustache是大小写敏感的
修改一下一些小bug
好我们可以看到现在已经生成我们预期的代码
我们先保存一下当前的代码
我们已经完成了代码生成的这一步
但是显然我们的method function top和我们的method map
他是还没有实现的
也就是说
虽然现在已经能够成功的解析和生成
但是我们的piccolo run time还是没有办法编译的
所以我们现在要添加一个
method function top
以及method map
同样实现一下这个红
复制一下paccessor
然后稍微修改一下
去除掉多余的代码
不能让我们的method使用起来feel是一样简单
所以我们希望模仿few accessor一样
编写一个method accessor
实现一下method accessor的函数
然后在type meta里面仿照fields
提供一个get methods list的功能
这样我们就可以遍历一个tab上面
所有的methods
因为我们添加了amethods
我们仿照m field处理一下
维护amethods相关的代码
啧啧啧
然后编译一下
修复一些小bug
这里是因为没有前置声明
然后字打错了
然后少了一个s
还有一个get method name
忘了实现了
再次编译就通过编译了
我们再把当前的代码再存储一下好
我们终于给我们的反射系统
实现了一个最简单的void函数的反射功能
但是我们现在还没有验证过它
接下来我们要去run component里面
真正实现我们的invoke函数
然后看一下我们的反射能不能符合我们的预期
假设我们已经取到了我们的目标类型
然后我们可以在它上面找到我们的
找到我们想要调用的函数
我们调用invoke
通过反射去执行我们的目标函数
好接下来就是如何去找到我们的目标类型
其实整个过程和我们前面的set和get
里面的过程类似
不过这里需要注意的是
如果我们的目标函数是在component上
那么我们不能像get和set一样
直接调用get component field函数
而是需要自己去找到对应的component
我们可以判断一下target name里面有没有点
如果没有点的话
就说明我们的目标函数
其实是component上面的一个成员函数
那么我们直接找到对应的component
然后再去找它上面的函数就可以了
第二种情况是
我们的目标结构是一个component上面的字段
那么我们可以调用find component field
去找到对应的字段
然后再调动卡
编译一下
运行起来可以看到我们的get off star dead logic
已经成功打印出来了
也就是说
我们成功使用反射
调用到了我们component上面的一个函数
在这一次代码解读中
我们使用反射系统
实现了脚本对component字段的读写
然后为反射系统增添了简单函数的反射功能
最后实现了脚本对component函数的简单调用
但是我们的函数反射
现在只能反射最简单的一种函数
如何才能让所有类型的函数都能被反射呢
欢迎大佬们在评论区或者pyo开发者频道
分享你的思路
也可以直接在github发起pr
帮助皮克罗引擎实现这一功能